pour le chanteur et politiciens steven
cafouillis elles ne sont pas bien loin
les années où les autochtones
subissaient les décisions des bla c'est
un gouvernement nommé par ottawa qui l'a
arraché à sa famille et placés dans un
pensionnat où il a été agressé
sexuellement à répétition dans les
années 1970 le peuple des territoires du
nord ouest à moitié autochtone a pris le
contrôle de ces institutions dans ce
parlement en forme d'igloo les
traditions autochtones ont transformé
les pratiques héritées du système
britannique
le gouvernement en est un de consensus
inspiré de vieille tradition autochtone
explique l'ancien premier ministre
stephen cac win for every gauche
autrefois raconte-t-il tout le monde
chat c'est en automne
nos ancêtres devaient se partager le
territoire le tipi qui est encore bien
présent servait de lieu où les familles
discuter pendant des jours jusqu'à ce
qu'un consensus permettent de commencer
la chasse et se cache cache
ici comme ailleurs l'élection se joue à
la porte de chaque résidence dans 19
circonscriptions des candidats
indépendants sans parti tente d'obtenir
le vote des électeurs
ensuite les 19 élus votent secrètement
pour un président d'assemblée un premier
ministre et six ministres
il reste onze simple député à
l'assemblée pour chaque enjeu tous les
députés peuvent s'exprimer et
théoriquement les discussions pourraient
s'éterniser comme autrefois sous le tipi
une idée qui a ses limites selon cette
experte en gouvernance autochtone au
quotidien ça ressemble plutôt à un
gouvernement minoritaire ou les
ministres forme le gouvernement et les
simples députés l'opposition et sans
parti il manque une vision à long terme
pour cet immense territoire qui dépasse
largement yellowknife
malgré tout steven cac oui parce que
l'esprit de consensus permet de penser à
tout le monde de la vente ni personne il
suggère aux politiciens fédéraux de s'en
inspirer de tenir compte de l'opinion
des députés de tous les partis et de
tous les horizons